[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 87 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mike how are
you doing I'm doing very well today how
are you doing France asked very happy
back from couple days of holidays very
well-deserved holidays you asked me yeah
yeah and very excited about continuing
our episodes on the same topic of not
support but like the relationship
between customers and Google cloud
platform yeah we've got a nice little
theme going of basically sort of what
our relationship ends up being with our
customers and how we so interact with
them in in a really good way I think
yeah and today we have Jonathan jam and
he's a customer engineer so we will
cover what is a customer engineer what
is the difference between a software
reliability engineer what is the
customer really the engineer what is a
solutions engineer there's a lot of them
so we're gonna be talking about what is
exactly what a customer engineer does
it's actually really cool and then we'll
have a question of the week for those
that love online content you listening
to a podcast so I'm assuming that
sometime I like online content so if
you're not able to access Meetup because
there's no local meetup in your town
how can you access to that company but
before that we're gonna go with cool
things of the week we have three of them
and the first one I'm gonna let you go
for it because you're the one that
proposed it we've recently opened up a
region in Sydney which is pretty
exciting and one of our partners there
accompanied by a I'm gonna miss you
missed three weeks it's three wks one of
the be three wakes could be could be
three wakes could be three weeks not
good then you of that and then but maybe
whatever anyway three wk yes whatever
that means the author of the article is
someone named Andrew Walker he wrote a
interesting piece about basically why
they prefer Google over some of our
competitors around our automation
particularly around the Surrealists
quote unquote AG and why they felt that
basically people would save money when
using us over other cloud providers it's
got pre pictures I think is basically
everything it has a lot of pretty
pictures in it yeah it has really really
really pretty pictures but also I like
that they actually share how
much they're saving with their own
project I do not know if those amounts
will match to whatever savings all the
people might get but they're pretty
impressive like we talked about how
they're pouring costs drop by 80% when
they move to Google which which is very
nice but you know if like if you're
using things like bigquery and appengine
all of those things are completely
managed that doesn't really surprise me
actually fantastic I think you had the
next one so the next one is a new
algorithm you've all used TCP that's for
sure and seeing TCP stands for
congestion and there's an algorithm that
if you went through school to learn
these things you might remember how it
works and it's really complicated and
not only it's very complicated but at
the same time it's not incredibly
performing there's a little bit of a
problem on it has a long time to
actually get to use the whole bandwidth
of network because it starts by
basically uploading little by little and
that among other things by for instance
a Chrome rather than having one TCP
connection establishes six of em to
avoid these problems now the thing is
that that algorithm was not the only
possible solution and someone came up
with a new solution so there's a new
congestion algorithm for TCP it's called
bbr which stands for bottleneck
bandwidth and round-trip propagation
time and basically the only thing
variation time is silent
PBR PT the whole idea is that it's it's
still TCP a lot like TCP you use it like
TCP but it will make it so it uses
better the bandwidth that is all to use
which is really good awesome I'm so glad
you can explain that because I have no
idea yeah basically I like that in the
article that we linked from the show
notes they also talked a little bit
about the benefits for Google cloud
platform customers and they show a
little bit the difference between like
the maximum round trade time so the
bigger the round-trip time the slower it
takes for you to receive data basically
that's the ping time and in some cases
it went down things for India went down
by 50% Wow crazy so yeah like you will
see that many of your operations
never
corporation will be much faster than
before it is not necessarily because we
have the best network in the world but
also because we have algorithms that
help so it's definitely worth checking
out any of you know Korea's about just
enjoy yeah you just have the benefits
really without having to do anything
yep cool and finally we want to talk
about a cool new product I think this is
kind of cool
basically it is introducing the transfer
appliance for Google cloud platform you
may remember back on episode 31 we
talked about basically be able to do
offline media import and export with
some about third parties so if you need
to like put data on a hard drive and
send it to us quite often that's the
fastest way of getting data to us as
they put it in the article via
sneakernet
they said yeah truck and people yeah we
had the two options one thus sending
hard this the other one is it's
something that is very regular where you
can also set up your own connection
directly to a data center but if you
have say your own data centers and or
even just your own racks and you're like
hmm
I kind of need to move like a petabyte
of data the petabyte is a bit yeah
that's big it might be a couple of hard
drives maybe four or five five hundred
something like that we actually have
this appliance now that you can put
directly in your rack custom appliance
that you can put directly in that will
take about what does a capacity of up to
one petabyte compressed which makes it
super super fast for you to drop your
data on it because it sits directly in
your rack and then you can send it to us
and instead of it kind of you know if
you're gonna send it over the network
that might take oh I don't know hundreds
of days you can now and sort of get it
in like a matter of weeks which with
that kind of size of data that can save
you a lot of time yeah I wonder how he
actually connects like I'm pretty sure
that it is pretty standard because it's
just a box that you can plug into your
data center so I don't know if it's like
sketchy or whatever that is but it's
just really really really really
incredibly big hard disk yep but it's
also really cute looking it is very cute
yeah there's two options there's the
thinner one with 100 terabytes and the
slightly thicker one with 480 terabytes
480 terabytes is a lot of terabytes
that's a lot of Tara but it's more
talked about than I have oh yeah I'm
thinking that my my big hardiest that I
use for recording
I think it's 4 terabytes so this would
be 120 discs of the
I only have somewhere like 15 terabytes
at home I think oh wait no terabytes oh
yeah yeah yeah no it is it is just a
crazy amount of data so yeah a little
bit bigger than floppy disks so that
sounds really good why don't we then
head off over and have a chat with
Johnathan Cham to chat all about
customer engineers sounds good
I am very excited to have another member
of the Google cloud platform family
joining us today to talk to us about
customer engineers Johnathan Cham how
are you doing I am doing very well and I
am very happy to be here talking to my
favorite Google celebrities of course
I'll ask you for your autographs later
yeah we can do that I can totally do
that yeah all right the funny thing is
is normally at the beginning of every
episode when people come on we ask them
so who are you and what do you do but
we're actually here to talk about who
are you and what do you do so I do a lot
but yeah my name is Johnathan Cham I'm a
customer engineer at Google I support
many of the Bay Area companies here and
so if you are one of them listening
perhaps you have already met me so what
is a customer engineer we've had many
kinds of engineers in the podcast we
have several ability engineers we have
software engineers we have reliability
engineers we have many many engineers
what is a customer engineer yeah that's
a really good question and I'm gonna
kind of spin this back on you guys what
do you think is a customer engineer and
there's no right answer right I mean
there's no wrong answer no right answer
everyone's got their own opinion it's
like a customer reliability engineer but
he's not reliable person comes late just
always yeah I think so yeah so basically
a customer unreliable and exactly there
we go okay all right all right I hate to
say it but that's totally yeah I mean so
yeah I can tell you a little bit about
what a customer engineer is but I have
to first provide a disclaimer because
you know opinions on my own and not the
views of my employer this is a
relatively new role within Google
I mean maybe within the last year and as
we continue to grow Google cloud
platform we wanted to provide the
customer with a resource that they can
have access to when it comes to building
their application on GCP so in short
words our ultimate goal is to help the
customer be successful on Google cloud
platform and own that end and technical
relationship with them we're a single
stateful interface to the customer and
because we're that stateful interface it
allows us to provide more strategic
guidance to help them make these
technical decisions regarding Google
cloud platform so I'm guessing in theory
then if I'm a customer and I'm thinking
to myself I'm gonna build the next big
thing whatever that happens to be and
I'm thinking how do I store my data or
how do i scale this out or how do I do
authentication I can come to you with my
ideas and you can be like this is good
or this is bad or something in between
that's perfect yeah that's exactly what
it is actually would you like an analogy
I can give you a good analogy all right
so it's good not perfect but I consider
us like doctors you know and our
customers our patients so let me ask you
real quick you know what do you look for
in a doctor lying to me I like my
doctors to lie to me to be untrustworthy
I just want them to tell me that
everything's gonna be fine yeah yeah
there's some of that right you know we
like to tell our patients everything's
gonna be fine but I mean when you look
for a doctor you want someone who you
can trust someone who's knowledgeable
someone that knows you very well right
so listen and ask good questions and so
you know imagine you know you come in
and you say hey hey dr. Jonathan champ I
have MCs syndrome you know which stands
for like massive container syndrome I
know have you had have you heard of that
I mean is that kubernetes massive
container syndrome it's a syndrome where
you have just way too many containers so
well you know what are your symptoms
right spending too much time managing
containers can't scale up and down my
app quickly enough and on my spreadsheet
that lists where my containers are
running is getting too complex I mean
these are symptoms of MCS and it's
getting widespread okay I'd say come to
you with this and you're like I have
this for you yes and you know of course
I'll ask a couple more questions about
their goal do you have you know what
other symptoms you have and after
listening we kind of do some diagnosis
and prescribing right maybe here's some
medication it's called kubernetes
it's effective it's potent it'll help
you with that syndrome you know the only
side effect is that you'll have to
manage all that infrastructure yourself
install configure update and build out
the kubernetes cluster very affordable
accepts all health insurances another
medication you know drug called Google
container engine and no side effects
higher efficacy but just as potent as
kubernetes it'll work much faster but
the drug costs just marginally more than
kubernetes so I mean you get the analogy
the senses we you know we come in listen
to their problems and try to provide
some diagnosis on what they want to do
yeah so we interviewed someone that was
a strategic customer engineer working
specifically for platinum customers
right and nice curious about to become a
platinum customer you actually need to
use the cloud to a point where like if
you overuse it we notice what about
customer customer engineers this is for
everyone is this for like can a new
customer just come directly and get one
yeah so a lot of new customers typically
you know as we're growing we are
starting to assign customer engineers to
a lot of accounts and what that means is
that they might hear from us if they
want to be proactive I know this sounds
a little salesy but you go to the
cloud.google.com website you know go to
slash sales and you tell them you know
who you are what you do there's a very
very good chance that you already have a
customer engineer that you don't know
about okay so basically anyone who is
thinking about getting involved with
customer engineers or wants to get
started on the program they're able to
do that now and go and go there and get
started yeah I mean if you're part of a
you know legitimate organization that's
using Google Cloud I mean if you're
running your own personal blog website
you're probably not going to kind of
customer engineer I don't know I mean do
you guys have a customer engineer for
your GCP podcast com no maybe we should
maybe we should yeah well I'll find out
who that is you know but yeah I mean
typically the size of the organization
usually doesn't matter it's a matter of
how much are you using TCP so that's
actually an interesting question you say
this is for people who are already using
GCP what if somebody isn't yet using GCP
but once to like sort of have help
onboarding is that also in your role yes
that's absolutely part of my role and
that's actually part of kind of our
typical engagement right I mean a lot of
these initial meetings will have
customers who are not GCP customers
reach out through that same website
cloud google.com slash sales and they'll
say hey I'm using AWS or I'm using Azure
you know I'm interested in looking at
GCP and we'll go in tell them about GCP
but more importantly learn about what
they're interested in like why do they
want to talk to us you know a lot of
them want to talk about multi cloud
strategies they want to talk about you
know having high availability across
vendors so I mean not all clouds are
perfect and a lot of times customers who
might be happy with their current cloud
vendor who want to have a second cloud
vendor just as backup so that makes me
think so what does it look like when if
I'm like I'm a customer and and I want
to engage with the customer engineer how
would the doctor visit would like
following your metaphor do you wear a
coat do you wear white coat oh yeah
that'd be cool
yeah I'm first of all I make sure I
bring my lab coat with me that has my
Dame
you know doctors Jonathan Cham but yeah
I mean I alluded to some of this earlier
about the doctor analogy a lot of
customers reach out to us and sometimes
we'll reach out to them but initial
meetings for people who don't know GCP
we just discuss about what their goals
are I mentioned about multi cloud
strategies but they also want to hear
from Google right Google itself has a
lot of impact in the industry they want
to hear about trends within the market
you know just recently I was at a
healthcare executive briefing where I
spoke about the need to collect
information and there was a calcio
competition about predicting patient
healthcare costs and they were super
excited about that so you know they were
really surprised about the maturity of
where machine learning was these days so
I mean after initial meeting usually
there's something like oh okay
this sounds great GCP is cool let's see
how much I will gain or how much I'll
save money you know what what type of
value add benefits will I get from
moving so a lot of times they'll make us
do a cost analysis you know with all the
other vendors so when we do that a lot
and you know once they've committed to
using Google Cloud after they've done
kind of the analysis their paper
analysis they go okay
you know we've decided Google cloud
platform is a way to go we like bigquery
it's awesome totally unique and
differentiated we like data flow tell me
how to build my app you know so we'll
sit in a room for like three hours
talking about what they're doing today
where they want to go how much storage
do they have today just a lot of
questions and a lot of iteration goes on
and on throughout those meetings and in
terms of kind of how do you take that
into production I mean you know what do
you guys think is the percentage of
effort between taking it and building an
app in dev versus building an app in
production I mean do you care if it
actually runs knowing how hard things
normally are I guess it depends a lot on
whether you're running on App Engine or
container engine computers and stuff
like that but I'd say that yeah it's
probably 50% more time I'm making sure
that everything is actually monitored
the alerts are set up and stuff like
that yeah I mean you know a lot of the
times companies have kind of like their
minimal Viable Product you know they do
a little little quick demo running on a
single instant and like oh my gosh this
is what we want to do but when it comes
to building out putting that into
production for in other thousands or
hundreds of thousands of customers they
you know they need to focus on things
like reliability availability
manageability performance security
scalability I mean that list goes on and
on and on right so a lot of those
discussions kind of reiterate back and
forth making sure that as they deploy
this into production that they're
successful doing so well do you tend to
also engage like I'm guessing because
with there's multiple teams and we've
had someone here like maybe CRA that's
some big customers but like some more
teams things like that you also engage
with them across the board oh absolutely
yeah there's I mean there's a lot of
different people that are involved I
mean you know when I say all of this it
makes it sound like I'm actually doing
all the work but a lot of what we do is
just make sure we own that and and
technical relationships so sometimes if
the customer has a specific let's say
you know kubernetes error right we're
gonna bring in support that's not
something that I would be
troubleshooting for them you know
sometimes for large platinum customers
like you had mentioned before they have
a strategic customer engineer who
they've actually paid for to be there
hands-on person that will actually
sometimes you know
right code make sure everything's up and
running log all the feature requests
because these platinum customers have a
lot of features that they want that you
know we might not have so just making
sure that they're happy they do some of
that as well so for us we're kind of
just owning that end to end you know
from beginning all the way to you know
their next big project we want to be
that single point of contact so what is
the profile of a customer engineer are
you engineers are you salesman are you
both are you actually doctors well I
think it's a really good question I mean
people I think they adjusted our titles
to be customer engineers because a lot
of us really aren't coming from sales
backgrounds right a lot of these people
that were hiring are literally engineers
I mean some of them were engineers at
Google you know I sit next to a Google
developer and you decided hey I want to
be more customer-facing so I mean the
people who we hire by the way we are
hiring a ton of people so you know go to
google.com for customer engineer and see
if you can you know apply but yeah I
mean we're looking for all types of
people and you absolutely do not need to
have a kind of a sales background you
just need to be able to talk
intelligently in front of customers and
not be awkward that can that kind of
sounds not that different from the role
of developer advocate where we're
engineers but we need to talk not in
front of customers necessarily but in
front of like lots of people that's true
yeah we don't have that responsibility
of making sure production systems stay
up there we definitely do not yeah I
mean you know like the doctor we're
there for the good times and the bad
times right you know when things break
guess who they call you know they say
hey Jonathan are things down you need to
help us you know supports not responding
things like that so it's my job to help
you know what they call heard the cat's
yeah so that's actually a really good
point so it's not just a hey I'm gonna
help this person on board it's also the
ongoing relationship throughout time
absolutely yeah it's a it's a very
strategic role meaning that you know
you're with them throughout many
different initiatives not just one and I
think that's kind of where but you know
maybe we're dev rel or developer
advocate might differ from us is you
guys are doing all this awesome
evangelism helping customers you know
get use the platform but in the end you
don't have customers you're accountable
for
whereas you know we are we actually have
a set of customers who we are you know
totally responsible for if they don't do
well you know we are measured on how
they how well they do nice so for a
completely selfish point of view as a
developer advocate one of the things
that we do is we talk to people and ask
for feedback on our products so I'm now
wondering what kind of feedback do you
get from customers like what are the
things that people like oh that's so
cool
or maybe what are the kind of things
that people are kind of surprised about
yeah I can talk a lot about that because
yes I get all the greatness and all the
you know if this is a word badness from
all our customers but I mean yeah you
know the good things I hear are I think
number one and this is just more from a
technical perspective but like openness
right we have tensorflow Pachi being
kubernetes you know big table which is
HBase and we have what over three
hundred thousand commits on github I
mean these are things that no other
cloud vendor really has and it you know
it's not as strategic for them as it is
for Google I mean openness is really big
and for large companies this is very
important right they've actually you
know in the past they've had vendors
that have locked them in and they can't
get out and so for us to really be
pushing this openness around all these
open-source projects where we can tell
them look Google cloud platform is the
best place to run but hey if we're not
doing our job before we're not making
you happy you can always run any of
these on another cloud and that's a
really powerful statement you know
another good thing that I hear is cost
you know we usually we do come lower you
know between 20 to 50% lower but it
really depends right and I always like
to say you know we're not the the
Walmart of cloud vendors right it's
really our cost is lower because we can
scale at such high numbers I mean what
do we we have like what 1 to 2 billion
users I mean we already have a lot of
infrastructure in place so our economies
of scale are enormous people love our
GUI I don't know I mean I like to ask
you I mean our GUI is pretty awesome the
cloud shell oh there's nothing like it
one button boom you're in ready to go
that's probably one of the things that I
forget about how cool they are and when
I show it to people that have never used
Google co-op iPhone when they're like oh
you want to connect those nice let's
just click on SSH you know that's it and
people are like oh
I forget that that's like not like the
normal thing for people yeah it's
amazing and I don't know if you know but
they're coming out with like a code
editor in there too so really I mean
they're gonna turn that interface into
your single interface for everything
excellent all right so I'm just curious
like I think I think it's fair to have
the good with the bad
like what are what are people finding
frustrating this is sort of an oxymoron
but you know customers will say you know
we're not as feature-rich which is a
totally true statement right it's
factual there's a lot of features that
maybe a lot of cloud vendors might have
that we don't have I mean we're not
going to be able to match feature for
feature with you know another cloud
vendor that's been you know in existence
for much longer than we have so I mean
for example Postgres right it's a very
popular database we launched it in beta
in March of this year right but it's a
20 year old technology I mean people
have been using it for a very long time
and we just announced that in March and
to be fair we are launching products
like every day I don't know how you guys
keep up with the announcements but I
mean I get an announcement every day
about a new product we have a podcast
that's how we keep up yeah yeah but but
I see that it's an oxymoron because at
the same time we're releasing these kind
of traditional databases we're also
coming out at the same time spanner you
know global availability global
consistency you know like light years
ahead of what people actually need but I
you know in hindsight I mean I think it
is Google's job to really kind of meet
customers where they are right expand is
great but a lot of customers aren't
ready to move to something that light
years ahead I mean former Hadoop
co-creator I mean he said Google's
living a few years in the future and
sending us messages right it's true we
have all this technology we've had the
scale like crazy so we built all these
new platforms to allow us to do that but
you think about all the enterprises that
have been using on-prem technologies for
the last 20 years they're not there yet
right so what we're doing in the
meantime is yep we're investing in all
these great awesome technologies that
we've already built internally
externalizing them but at the same time
enabling our customers to slowly move
their traditional workloads like you
know leveraging postgrads and things
like that to to our Google cloud so I
think that's you know kind of you know
we're
where the features are we're still
catching up I don't know what do you
guys think yeah I think that in general
people tend to have the view that since
Google cloud tends to be quite like it's
it's a pretty young platform relatively
at least many of our features are pre
new people tend to feel like oh there's
it's not as mature I think that that but
at the same time what I say to that is
well yeah
like for instance spanner it's a
perennial feature a tip for your new
product but we've actually been using it
internally to power Google for quite a
long time there's an experience that is
internal that has helped us getting
there yeah and that's definitely a
pattern I've seen across numerous
products yeah yeah I think the good news
is though if you're building a new app I
mean there's really no feature that
we're lacking now if you have this old
app that uses a lot of these kind of
more older technologies you know there's
probably things that you children you'll
need that we might not have but I mean I
haven't talked to a customer where
there's like this one feature that's
like okay this is a deal breaker we
cannot use Google cloud like there's
always a workaround and I think that's
what makes us unique you know we always
have things that you can do that you can
work around any kind of technical
blocker do you get to see more customers
that are coming to Google with apps that
are ready exist and they're migrating
them to the cloud or do you see more
people that are building new
infrastructure new applications and
they're looking for the cloud as the
place to build them directly I think
there's a little bit of both I mean I've
so I actually have dealt with pretty
much three types of customers ones that
are already using a cloud vendor which
is the most difficult right I mean you
really have to convince them to you know
there's a lot of value to move the
Google cloud right it's not just cost
but there's an operational cost to move
you know all their employees are already
using you know another cloud vendors API
so you know there's that a migrating
from another cloud number two is moving
from on prep and a lot of these large
enterprises are using on-prem you know
they have their own physical Hardware
own data centers and trying to figure
out okay how do we map that to a Google
cloud platform as you know that that's
that's part of our role and then the
third one are customers who are building
new apps already you know they kind of
just said hey look GCP looks cool we're
going to start using GCP oh it's
actually working very well we're gonna
continue making investments in Google
cloud so I think those are the kind of
three profiles of customers that I
personally see and and there might be
more well so now I'm curious what are
the reasons that you're seeing people
moving right now I think there's a lot
of unfortunately a lot of people want to
save well not unfortunately but people
want to save money right and Google
cloud platform has a very very
aggressive cost structure so in terms of
like storage and compute we are
definitely cheaper and while you know I
don't like to emphasize like just come
to us because we're cheaper we do have a
lot of value-added products like
bigquery you know I think that's Dremel
right Dremel is the white paper yeah for
bigquery yeah I mean you know we've
we've had bigquery internally for many
years and there's nothing like it
being able to meet it I always tell
customer it's a three-step process
upload your data write your sequel query
run it I mean that's very powerful right
there's no more setting up
infrastructure there's no more updating
securing patching it's just getting real
value from from your data
instantaneously and so the trend that
I'm seeing across all customers and I
think just across the industry in
general is just people moving to manage
services right this is something that
you know people realize that the
operational aspect of managing the
infrastructure is not very valuable to
their business and they're trying to get
away from that so we're almost running
out of time but is there anything that
we haven't mentioned or you want to make
sure you plug or you just want our
audience to know about yeah if you want
to reach out to us I run a weekly online
Meetup just go to me.com slash GCP
online if you just search GCP online
meetup we do this weekly webinar slash
architecture slash you know just banter
back and almost like obviously not as
cool as the GCP podcast but you know we
do some kind of a webinar and demos on a
lot of these different products that we
talked about so you know join and
subscribe to us and you know we're happy
to interact with you cool all the fun
check it out
awesome well Jonathan thank you so much
for joining us this is a really great
conversation yeah thank you Mark Thank
You Francis thank you
a huge thanks to Jonathan for joining us
today it is really nice to hear what
happens not necessarily maybe
the scenes but behind customer
engagements that happen with us and some
of our customers it's really really nice
and how we like to basically take care
of them yeah I'm looking forward to
seeing his updated business card with
the new title customer unreliable
engineer we'll see if he actually does
that but before before we finish and
before I get fired let's talk about the
question of the week which is actually
very related to what Jeff and champ does
so the question was basically okay I am
in some random place in the world and
unfortunately I am NOT able to access
local meetups and if you're in San
Francisco there's a bunch of local
meetups and it's really cool that if
you're somewhere else where you can not
access those what do you do some of
those meetups actually record their dogs
and publish them but it's even better if
those meetups happen directly online and
I think that Jonathan champ does exactly
that
yeah so he runs or I think he helps run
anyway he's directly involved he's
somehow hosts the thing we just--we're
cuz online so I'm not sure what yeah but
yeah it is the Google cloud platform
online Meetup so there have been a
series I'm actually just going through
them now there's a lot of really cool
meetups have been going on for quite
awhile I want to say once a month or so
where they do live YouTube streaming of
presentations where you can interact
directly with a presenter and hang out
with a bunch of other people who are
also online watching the same thing yeah
I really like them there's one of them
that I will definitely want to watch
getting started quickly with machine
learning and Google cloud platform one
of the reasons why I want to watch it is
because I can see that there's a little
picture bender from Futurama yeah
definitely check it out the coolest part
of these is that it happens online
directly so it's not only you can watch
the video and ask questions in the
comments you can actually ask questions
to the speaker on real time which is
very very nice yeah and if you happen to
manage to miss it for whatever reason
they're available as well on YouTube put
a link in the show notes
yeah we're will excellent all right well
Fran says before we wrap up today are
you up to anything interesting and
exciting lately no I do not do anything
interesting anymore
I just I just published the episodes for
just Frank every two weeks and on Monday
I released one on how to do unique
testing of web servers in go which is
something that not that many people do
so if you're interested on it go check
it out just for fun gum and other than
that holidays what about you I'm gonna
hang out a little bit my next event will
be packs div and then PAX West which is
a late August early September so that's
in Seattle if you play games in there
games and love games then you probably
are familiar with these conferences
great well mark thanks so much for
taking the time today to again record an
amazing episode of Google Apple phone
podcast and thank you so much for
joining me and thank you very much to
everyone for listening as well they all
of next week the UL next week